Speaker 1: There's some super interesting
new polling that I want to talk about, about
the 2024 election and specifically about what
Republicans are thinking, and the bottom line
is Donald Trump's support is rapidly collapsing
among Republicans who ultimately will decide
is Donald Trump the 2024 Republican nominee
or is it going to be someone else?
Now we have seen already in January to pretty
sizable rallies.
And every indication that Donald Trump is
going to continue doing more of them in March,
he'll be speaking at the Republican National
Committee meeting some kind of mini convention
or event in New Orleans, Louisiana.
This is a guy who wants to be involved in
2022, and he wants to use 2022 as a way to
ultimately have the option to be the nominee
in 2024 if he so chooses.
Up until now, we've basically been saying
the 2024 nomination is Trump's for the taking.
If he wants it, it's now a question mark,
and we're going to look at some recent data
which shows at least some Republicans seem
to be getting sick of the guy.
And this is a very, very different situation
when one where it's Trump's if he wants it.
The Associated Press reporting Trump facing
legal and political headwinds as he eyes a
comeback.
And it references that video we showed you
last week where Trump referred to himself
on the golf course as the 45th and 47th president,
sort of alluding to a 2024 run.
And the article points out his popularity
among Republicans is declining somewhat, with
71 percent saying they have a favorable opinion
of Trump compared to 78 in September.
But the new poll shows only a narrow majority
of Republicans 56 percent want him to run
for president in 2024.
The poll found 44 percent do not want him
to run.
This is a very different situation to what
we had throughout most of 2021, particularly
the first part of the year 56 to 44 among
Republicans want him to run.
That's basically 50-50.
Now, of course, that's still fine for winning
the primary in the sense that if 56 percent
of Republicans support Trump and the other
44 percent support a bunch of other people,
some Ron DeSantis, some whoever, right?
Mitt Romney, Jeb Bush, Trump still wins with
that, but these are dramatically lower numbers
than we previously had.
Another interesting article in The Washington
Post.
Do Republicans love Donald Trump, as they
once did, which rates his support within the
party may not be quite as robust as it once
was.
And that is based on a lot of the same polling.
This one, though, references a Washington
Post University of Maryland survey completed
at the end of last year found that more than
six in 10 Republicans say there is evidence
of widespread voter fraud.
Nearly six in 10 say Biden's election was
not legitimate.
More Republicans say they want Trump to run
again in 2024.
Then they say, want another candidate?
But the margins, as we talked about 50, down
to 54 to 46.
And then lastly, there is a Marquette University
poll just looking at favorable versus unfavorable
on Trump.
And if you look now, you see that Trump's
favorability is down to only 32 percent.
Sixty seven percent now have an unfavorable
opinion of Donald Trump.
Only 32 percent have a favorable opinion of
Trump.
So there is going to be a real question here
as to whether this guy is actually viable.
This is great news now.
I don't want to praise Republicans for this.
I saw some commentaries online saying Republicans
are finally coming to their senses.
No, they're not.
Republicans are much the same as Donald Trump,
or it's what have I heard about recently.
And because Donald Trump has been sort of
out of the public spotlight for some period
of time, I think this is mostly an artifact
of that if there's no real alternative appealing
alternative to Trump.
I think it's completely reasonable and even
likely that Donald Trump will be back before
you know it and and popular.
But there's a very interesting kind of intermediate
period here where if Trump's role in the 2002
midterms is seeing more as a nuisance rather
than an advantage, and if some Trumpist candidates
lose in twenty two, which is just nine months
from now at this point and some new Republicans
not at all connected to Trump win, it may
just move the Republican Party into saying,
I don't know.
I think we're just kind of beyond Trump.
There's nothing.
Oral here were the Republicans have said we
cannot allow this again.
That was really bad.
It was bad for the country, it was bad for
the world.
It was embarrassing.
This is not about that.
This is just a sort of what have you done
for me lately, top of mind type thing.
And I think some Republicans are just kind
of like, Oh yeah, Trump, that guy.
I don't really know that I want him to run
again.
And as we saw, even from the people we talked
to at the Trump rally in Conroe, Texas, over
the weekend, it's not that these are reasonable
Republicans, it's that they just seem to be
thinking, maybe it's time for somebody else.
So we're going to keep watching these numbers
really closely.
But this is a significant shift away from
Trump, at least in recent polling